today on the mat wall show another
rapper was shot and killed this week
more and more of the people making music
glorifying violence or falling victim to
it themselves but while the left warns
about the dangers of irresponsible
speech all the time they seem to have a
blind spot when it comes to the rap
industry I wonder why also I am featured
in yet another mainstream media hit
piece this one from NBC News I'll tell
you about some of the dirty tricks they
pulled behind the scenes and Anne
Hathaway goes on The View to talk about
why abortion is a woman's Destiny what
the hell does that mean we'll talk about
all that and more today on the Matt
Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
continues to plague our economy the
daily wire reports that in less than two
years inflation has soared from 1.4
percent to 8.6 percent as of May 2022
the price of gasoline was up nearly 49
the price of meat poultry and fish was
up 14.2 percent and the price of used
cars was up 16 the current
administration's irresponsible spending
patterns including Biden's 1.9 trillion
dollar rescue plan continue to
exacerbate the problem now is not the
time to have all your money tied up in
the stock market don't let your savings
wither away hedge against inflation with
gold from Birch gold text Walsh to
989898 and Birch gold will send you a
free info kit on protecting your savings
with gold Birch gold is giving out a
free gold bar with any Purchase made by
December 22nd but you must submit your
claim to uh for this offer by Black
Friday with almost 20 years of
experiencing experience in converting
IRAs and 401ks into precious metal IRAs
Birch gold can help you to don't sit
around while the fed devalues your
harder earn money text Walsh 298-9898
and learn how you can convert at least
part of your savings into a precious
metals Ira if you place an order by
December 22nd Birch gold will send you a
free gold bar don't want to miss out
text Walsh to 989898
we begin today with Deja Vu a rapper has
been shot and killed uh you are I
suspect not overly shocked by this
development this time it was someone who
goes by the stage name takeoff and was
part of a popular rap group called Migos
the daily wire has more on the story
rapper takeoff was shot and killed in
Houston in the early Tuesday morning
according to TMZ the 28 year old
recording artist was part of the group
Migos law enforcement sources and
several witnesses told TMZ that the
Fatal incident occurred just after 2 30
a.m when police were called to 8 10
Billiards and bowling Houston the
sources said take off whose real name is
kirschnick Carrie ball was playing dice
with bandmate cuevo when a fight broke
out among participants this led to one
person allegedly opening fire and
striking takeoff in or near the head it
was pronounced dead at the scene to
other individuals who were also
allegedly injured during the altercation
taking the hospital but their conditions
unknown the sources said quavo was not
hurt so
take off now joins a lengthy list of
murdered rappers and it's a list that
seems to be growing with increasing
rapidity in recent months uh just this
past September the rapper p b rock was
shot and killed at a chicken and waffles
restaurant in Los Angeles couple months
before that in July a rapper named Jay
deyoungin was shot by multiple gunmen
who pulled up in a black truck and
opened fire while he was sitting outside
of his home in Louisiana that same month
a rapper named Trouble was killed in a
home invasion robbery in Atlanta overall
this year this year alone okay at least
seven rappers have been murdered that's
at least 15 since 2020.
five a year on average was which is an
extraordinary figure when you consider
that the murder rate for performers in
other genres is effectively zero
I mean there are more rappers killed in
a year than country singers killed in a
decade or a century or ever
that's not because there's some kind of
racist Vendetta against rappers there
isn't any serial killer on the loose
targeting hip-hop artists as far as I
know
the difference between rappers and
country stars of course is that rappers
live lifestyles of criminality and
violence they promote criminality and
violence they glorify criminality and
violence and then they fall victim to
the very brutality that they encourage
in fact I pulled up the lyrics to One
Migo song Totally at random uh because I
don't know any of their music I'm not
very familiar with the catalog so I just
looked it up and the first one that that
came up was a song called open it up
and the very first lines in the song are
shoot through your car door that's the
first line in the song then take off
raps open it up open it up Double Cup
feeling the Opium it's AK in the cut my
n words tote knit we're trying to look
appropriate don't show up and look at me
wrong I'm blowing it you trying to plot
and we know in it throw away I shoot a
pistol then throw it my n-word shoot
without warning
now we've grown of course Very
accustomed to this sort of content in
rap songs it's not at all shocking or
surprising at this point
but still I mean really think about what
he's saying here he's bragging about
murdering human beings simply because
they look at him funny
he is boasting of and thereby promoting
murderous savagery
he's saying that he'll kill you for no
reason
and then someone killed him for no
reason
my point is not that this young man
deserved to be murdered I mean nobody
deserves to be killed over a game of
dice it's a tragic senseless waste of
human life and potential
my point is that rap music has helped to
create a culture of crime and brutality
and that culture has become so pervasive
so out of control that even the rappers
themselves are falling victim to it
every other month now they're being
eaten by the Beast they create
they're not operating in a vacuum of
course I mean they're merely the front
men they're the salesmen knocking on
your door peddling this filth but behind
them is the entire music industry which
is run by much wealthier people who know
exactly what they're doing they know how
poisonous the product is and they know
that many of their salesmen are dying by
it
and they don't care
but as rap music it's more dumb and gets
more brutal more violent more toxic it
also becomes more and more mainstreamed
and ubiquitous
in my brief Research into Migos I found
a picture of the three members of the
band posing on the red carpet at the
Nickelodeon's Kids Choice Awards
because what could be more appropriate
for children than music that explicitly
encourages them to commit drive-by
shootings
of course the apologists will absurdly
claim that music lyrics are just words
they don't influence anyone
go into any city in America and you will
see Legions of young fatherless kids
explicitly acting out the lyrics in the
music that they are listening to every
second of the day and yet we're supposed
to believe that they're not influenced
at all
it is an outrageously stupid claim in
reality human beings are influenced by
words and ideas
we are especially when those words and
ideas are communicated through music
so it's not that they're influential as
long as it's not music it's the other
way around it's especially influential
in music there's a reason why brands
have uh most corporate brands have their
own little advertising Jingles because
words on their own can have immense
Powers but when you set them to music
they become embedded in your brain in
your soul
they become a mantra a slogan to live
your life by
to a young fatherless black kid in the
city
rap music isn't just music it's a it's a
lifestyle it's a message about how to
live it's a message about how to conduct
yourself how to be a man
and these are kids who are not getting
that message anywhere else they don't
have role models showing them how to be
men
or they get it they get it from rap
music
it is a guide it is a map
pointing the child towards his own
destruction
now of course
here's the irony here
the left will agree with everything I'm
saying about the Power of Words and idea
ideas
except when it comes to rap music
you know they will say that if you use
biologically correct pronouns to refer
to a trans person that you are then
directly causing the trans person to
kill himself
if you say criticize a hospital for
mutilating minors
your words are directly causing violence
and bomb threats against the hospital
if you say question the election results
in 2020 your words directly led to the
riot on January 6th
they directly caused a crazy homeless
guy to break into Nancy Pelosi's house
and assault her husband with a hammer
in all of these contexts
and in any other context where
conservatives are saying anything about
any subject
words we're told have enormous
consequence
but when rappers spend decades
explicitly glorifying and encouraging
Street violence
and lots of people who listen to that
music commit acts of Street violence
sometimes committing them against the
rappers themselves
the very people who are just sermonizing
about the Power of Words and ideas will
throw their hands up and say
I don't know I don't see a connection
here
I just I I don't see it I don't know
what you guys are talking about
words have consequences
unless they're said over a base heavy
beat
in which case they exist in this kind of
consequence-free Zone apparently
yet we know that that's not the case at
all
in fact in few areas of life
do words have greater consequences
or Worse consequences
than in the rap industry
consequences that even now the people
peddling this stuff
can't escape
now let's get to our five headlines
well the midterm elections are here and
I hope you're ready to vote because all
435 seats in the House of
Representatives and 35 seats in the
Senate are up for grabs we need to fill
these roles with the most qualified
people which is no easy task fortunately
not every role has to be has to be that
difficult to fill especially if you're
hiring for your business with zip
recruiter zip recruiter does the work
for you and you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com Walsh how does
ZipRecruiter make hiring faster and
easier well when you post your job on
ZipRecruiter it uses powerful technology
to find and match the right candidates
with your job and it sends them to you
it's as easy as that you can easily
review those recommended candidates and
invite your top choices to apply four
out of five employers who post on
ZipRecruiter get a qualified candidate
within the first day if you want a
better way to find great people for your
team try
ziprecruiter.com Walsh once again that's
ziprecruiter.com Walsh w-a-l-s-h
ZipRecruiter the smartest way to hire
the assailant in the Paul Pelosi case
has been in custody for a few days and
more information is coming out the
media's job then of course is to
organize that information in such a way
as to support their already pre-decided
predetermined narratives so here's the
Washington Post
it says the path that led an attacker to
the home of house Speaker Nancy Pelosi
was long and Meandering with evidence
suggesting that he dabbled in Fringe
movements of All Sorts before embracing
the right-wing vilification of Democrats
the complex history of accused attacker
David de Pape and his radicalization
unfolded over more than eight years and
several different ideologies moving from
Green Party Support and nudist activism
to a hateful mix of racist anti-jewish
and misogynistic rhetoric according to
terrorism analysts who've studied his
writings on social media posts they say
to pape's evolving beliefs show how
today's extremist threat complicates
easy left-right categorization a shift
that's confusing to the public and a
bonanza for trolls who exploit the
messiness to push disinformation and
justify violence Cynthia Miller Idris
who heads the polarization and extremism
research and Innovation Lab at American
University says you get stuff that just
feels contradictory but when you
understand how online exposure to
propaganda works it makes perfect sense
it's a Choose Your Own Adventure type of
radicalization by the time to paint 42
allegedly broke into Pelosi's residence
on Friday and attacked 82 year old Paul
with a hammer his writings were Laden
with far-right messaging that indicated
a dark conspiratorial spiral his blog
post in October were a mix of bloody
images and hateful screeds aimed at a
variety of targeted groups including
Jewish black and trans people as well as
Democrats he also shared delusional
thoughts about an invisible fairy that
sometimes appeared as a bird
a reported a purported former romantic
partner
oxane Gypsy Tobe has told reporters that
the Pape is mentally ill
well he's talking about an invisible
fairy so I think that's probably a
pretty good indication
but Washington Post says those details
were largely ignored by right-wing
figures including elected Republicans
and magistars with millions of followers
who instead reached years back to
portray him as a leftist hemp bracelet
peddling hippie perhaps part of a false
flag operation to blame the right for
the assault
now
now all right so a couple of things here
just to be clear with you Washington
Post
we aren't ignoring the details
yeah it's not about ignoring the details
the point and the problem for us and for
you I suppose
is that we don't trust you
so uh the task is always to discern
which details are correct and which are
lies which are out of context Etc
and there's no perfect way to figure it
out I mean how are we supposed to know
that's the thing something like this
happens uh it's at Nancy Pelosi's house
and San Francisco I have no direct
access to information about it I there's
no way that I can really investigate it
on my own okay I'm not going to show up
to the crime scene with a notepad and
start uh and start doing my own
investigation I don't think they'd
allowed me to do it anyway so
uh I along with everybody else you know
we have to rely
on the disseminators of uh the the the
institutions that have positioned
themselves as the official kind of
disseminators of information and that
would be like you
but the problem is that you have shown
time and time again that you are totally
untrustworthy
and so that's the spot we're in you just
I don't know I mean maybe what you're
telling us is 100 correct maybe it's 80
correct
maybe it's 50 50. I don't know
and so all of the the the speculation
the what you call conspiracy theories
these are just people who are aware that
they can't trust you lying hacks and so
they're trying to make sense of it on
their own
what else are they supposed to do I mean
it's either we ignore these stories
completely and just say I I don't care
move on with our lives
that's certainly a valid option you know
um or we just accept everything you tell
so I know we can't do that
and so the only third option is to if we
don't want to ignore it we can't accept
everything said it's just it's just to
try to make sense of it as I said make
sense of it ourselves
and so that's what people are doing it
is all your fault I mean it's really 100
your fault all of the conspiracies the
so-called conspiracy theories online
what you call uh misinformation
disinformation it is 100 all your fault
you you have yourselves to blame for
that
when you put yourself in the position
of being the Arbiters of information the
Arbiters of what is true and what is not
but you don't live up you don't even
come close to living up to that uh
to that to the responsibilities of that
position then you know it's a it's a
free-for-all
all that said personally and I said this
from the very beginning I have no
problem accepting the basic outline
presented by The Washington Post and
other mainstream media Outlets about
this story
the basic outline of a guy breaking into
Nancy Pelosi's house getting into a
physical altercation with her husband
I'm from the very beginning there's
nothing about that that seems strange to
me
and the reason why it doesn't seem
strange to me is that this is San
Francisco
and there are this kind of thing happens
in San Francisco all the time now it
might not happen to politicians all the
time but it happens all the time
this is a city overrun by by criminality
overrun by violent criminals overrun by
drug-addled crazy homeless people
and so I hear this and I think yeah well
that's well I mean she lives in San
Francisco
and the details that we're getting now
just uh just only confirm that
so this conversation of was he on the
left was he on the right he was crazy
this is a crazy person this is not he
was radicalized by right-wing rhetoric
okay there despite what we're told from
the extremism experts that work at these
universities and have now just
positioned themselves
you know they position that the media's
position itself is the Arbiters of
information then you have people in
universities who they're now the experts
on extremism
let me do the expert on that like who
what do you know about this topic that
anyone else doesn't know well because
that's what I am
so the experts tell us that yeah well
there's a pipeline that takes someone
from uh this makes perfect sense someone
goes from a a far left nudist
uh activist
in the green party
to a Maga extremist as a pipeline goes
right from one another no there's not
there's no pipeline there
in between those two
you know spots on the specs it's not
even us can't even call it a spectrum
because there's this there's this
vast Canyon divide between the two
um so this is not radicalization this is
not uh you know he was responding to
stuff that uh Ted Cruz said or you know
I think they they also tried to blame
Jesse waters on Fox News
this is just a crazy drug crazed
homeless guy and that's what he is
okay he believes that invisible there
are visible fairies all around
who radicalized him into that belief
I'll tell you what radicalized him into
that belief uh crack cocaine heroin
something like that
this is a crazy violent person
doing what lots of crazy violent people
in San Francisco have done
which is why the real story here again
as I said from the beginning
is that you know in its proper context
this is understood as a local crime
story in San Francisco
not unlike so many others that we hear
of every single day
this is a consequence not of Fox News
or conservatives uh or people being
skeptical about the 2020 election
results or conservatives tweeting things
not a consequence of that
this is a consequence of local
Democratic Leadership in San Francisco
that allows violent crazy drug-addicted
homeless people to just run rampant with
no consequence
and from what I understand even this guy
apparently was uh he's a Canadian
citizen has overstayed his visas an
illegal he's here illegally should have
been deported
well we know the Democrat leaders in
these cities are not quick to do that
either it was a sanctuary City San
Francisco is
Sanctuary Sanctuary City not just for
illegals but for violent crazy homeless
people
if you were if if they were enforcing
the law in this city and focused on Law
and Order is when it happened because
this guy would be in jail or he'd be in
a mental institution or he would have
been deported up to Canada let him be
their problem
so this is this is a Democrat politician
Nancy Pelosi
who has helped to facilitate the
destruction of Law and Order
um now falling victim to the Anarchy and
Chaos that she has helped to create
through the policies that she supports
that's the story here
and all the other details about what
this guy believed or what he posted on
his blog while he was uh imagining that
invisible fairies were flying around
that means nothing
how about it forced the law in your damn
City about that how's that for an idea
Republicans cannot be blamed for any
crime in San Francisco okay that's not
on any Republicans entirely on the
Democrats
you own every part of that everything
that happens in San Francisco you own it
that's yours
speaking of not being able to trust the
media um here's another reason why this
is a story from I want to say here's a
story from NBC News by a reporter named
Matt Levites
here's the headline
far right figures appear to be testing
Twitter's boundaries for anti-lgbtq
speech Elon Musk the new owner of
Twitter has built himself as a champion
of free speech and vowed to prevent
Twitter from becoming a free for free
for all hellscape so this is a story
that he already tweeted it out to when
he said it in his tweet he said that uh
you know there are a bunch of
conservatives and far-right figures who
are uh
tweeting slurs against LGBT people now
so that's the way this is Being Framed
so we're it's hate speech we're we're uh
you know engaging in slurs and all that
kind of thing here's the article in the
few days since Elon Musk closed his deal
to buy Twitter far-right users have
started to celebrate what they hope will
be the ability to freely use homophobic
and transphobic rhetoric and make
threats on the social media platform on
Saturday former UFC fighter Jake Shields
who has over 340 000 Twitter followers
appear to be testing the boundaries of
the company's moderation apparatus by
posting a photo of a drag queen smiling
at a young drag performer with the
caption this is a groomer Shields added
I was suspended for this exact tweet a
month ago so we'll see if Twitter is now
free the word grooming has long been
associated with mischaracterizing LGBT
people particularly gay men and
transgender women as child sex abusers
on Friday conservative podcaster Matt
Walsh who describes himself as a
Theocratic fascist lauded musk's
acquisition of the company and
encouraged his over one million
followers to start misgendering trans
people
we've made huge strides against
transgender Walsh tweeted in just a year
we've recovered many years of ground of
uh of ground conservatives have
previously surrendered The Liberation of
Twitter couldn't have come at a more
opportune time now we can ramp up our
efforts even more
laws are changing and public opinion is
changing Walsh who held an anti-trans
protest in Nashville attended by
thousands last month continued we have
done all this intentionally it was all
part of the plan that we laid out and
executed okay so I I make it into the
article of course and now and I could go
and get and he gets the libs of tick
tock and a couple others
at no point does he actually provide an
example of a quote far-right person
um using a slur
and at no point do is it does he give
any example of um anyone making threats
or encouraging threats
there are no examples of that that's how
the article is set up there are no
actual examples of it
um the word groomer is not a slurp it is
an accurate description of what these
people are doing
it's not a compliment either but it's
when we're accurately describing your
evil Behavior there's no there's no
complimentary way to describe it
um I did say that I'm I'm looking on
forward to going on a misgendering spree
on Twitter I've been saying that all
along
but of course by misgendering I mean
correct gendering
so that's not a slur either
no actual examples even though that was
what I was trying but here's the point
in in the original article now this is
apparently has been changed
but the original article says
um after the part where they're quoting
me
uh the reporter claims that he reached
out to me and I didn't respond to a
request for comment
okay
well and that has that language has been
removed
but it was there originally
well this reporter he reached out to me
yesterday morning and told me that he's
working on an article he's right he's
writing an article about you know the
anti-eligibility rhetoric and he he just
love he'd love to get my take on it
because I'm going to be included in the
article and he'd love to get my
perspective as well in fact he begins
his message hope you're well
exclamation point but he'd love to get
my uh he'd love to get my opinion on it
he says
in fact I can pull it up I'll tell you
exactly what he
I'll tell you exactly what he said okay
so he he wrote me yesterday I said this
is yesterday 8 21 a.m he says hi Matt
hope you're well I'm writing an article
for NBC news regarding the uptick and
what many would call charged rhetoric
over lgbtq issues what many would call
that's what he is calling it but he said
this it's what many people are saying
I'm going to be quoting a tweet of yours
from the other day and therefore want to
reach out for comment let me know if
you'd like to expand on your thoughts on
this topic looking forward to hearing
from you
so it's yesterday 8 21 am
and I got this message and I've been
around the block a little bit with these
people I know how it works so he says
he's writing article I got the message
at uh I don't know I saw it 10 minutes
later
and so I went and checked I went to
nbcnews.com and what do you know the
article's already been posted and it was
already posted long before he sent the
request for coming they posted it at
around five o'clock in the afternoon the
previous day
and then he waits for for the afternoon
and evening to pass and then the
following day reaches out to me and says
that he's writing the article right now
and wants to get my comment and not only
that but in the original version of the
article again it said that they reached
out to me and I didn't respond but they
didn't reach out to me and at the time
when they when they published it they
had not reached out to me
they were just anticipating that I
wouldn't respond and so they they
claimed it as if it had happened
um and I saw this and I and I messaged
him back and said hi Matt I see that
you've already published your article
timestamp seems indicated it was
published the day before you reached out
for comment is that correct
he says yes the original version of the
story was published yesterday we'd
appreciate your comment on this topic if
you have anything to add
and I did have something to add and I
messaged back I said I think you
understand that it's a tactic to publish
a story wait until the initial push of
traffic has died down and then ask for
comment from the people you've smeared
in the article I don't care if you guys
are partisan vultures masquerading as
journalists I just preferred if you
didn't insult my intelligence by
pretending that you want to hear my
perspective for an article that you
published yesterday
haven't had a response after that after
I after that
this is the tactic of course they
published the article with all the
smears and everything making claims uh
you made threats you you uh you you
engaged in slurs and all the rest of it
then you get the initial push of traffic
get the traffic overnight you wait till
the traffic has died down and no one's
reading the article anymore now it's NBC
news so not that many people are going
to read it to begin with but
um like 90 of the people who will read
it will read it in the first few hours
that's just the way that it works uh
that's just that's the nature of the
beast when you're in the content
creation space on the internet and they
know that so the following day it's like
no one's reading it anymore and then
we'll we'll update it with your comments
these people are as I said to him in my
response these people are partisan
vultures and then and then they have the
nerve
uh as I said it annoys me
the fact that they're soulless lying
hacks I get that part of it okay I
accept that
um but yeah it's just insulting my
intelligence I don't I don't like
you know don't insult my intelligence
you think I'm stupid enough to buy this
you use a tactic like this and I'm not
going to notice
it's like it's like I say to my kids
sometimes when I you know I tell them to
go clean their room and then they go up
there and they just shove everything
right under the bed like and I can and I
can see it poking out from under the bed
and I come up and and I say the same
thing like don't insult my intelligence
kids this is this is you think I've you
know I was a kid myself
you you want you want to get away with
not cleaning your room you're just going
to put everything under the bed like I'm
not gonna notice that
like I haven't like I didn't do that
myself as a kid come on
they're gonna try to fool me at least
put a little bit put a little bit more
effort into it
say the same thing to these people in
the media
um but then on top of it they have the
nerve to be offended
when people don't believe them
when they tell us the official version
of the story like with Nancy Pelosi and
we don't immediately accept it they pull
stunts like this
and then are upset when we don't
immediately accept everything they say
right all right Hillary Clinton uh
really might be running in 2024. I
didn't believe it at first I you know I
thought as naive as I am I thought that
uh I I just I didn't think that she
would go for a third time around but
she's been all over the place recently
and here she is with Joy Reed expressing
her concern for Nancy Pelosi
I want to take this a step further away
from the incident that terrible incident
with Paul Pelosi and broaden it out
because what we have with the rhetoric
coming from uh the Republican uh
candidates from their party right now is
so disturbing I didn't see a big
outpouring on the part of elected
officials to stand with Nancy Pelosi the
way she has stood with Republicans as
well as Democrats in times of real
terror like on January the 6th and so
ask yourselves please why would you
entrust power to people who are either
themselves unable to see how terrible it
is that someone would be attacked in
their home or don't really care because
they think it will somehow get them
votes that will get them elected this is
a real threat to the heart of our
democracy
threat to my I I'm shocked to hear her
say that it was a threat to democracy
you know those those words have a lot of
power and they resonate a lot because
you know Democrats they they rarely call
anything a threat to democracy you
rarely hear them say they only say it in
every single sentence they speak okay
it's only every time they open their
mouth they call something a threat to
democracy and so given that they bring
it up so rarely uh when you hear that it
it really it it sinks in doesn't it you
sit up and you listen uh threat to
democracy and the threat to democracy in
this case is that she says not enough
Republicans are concerned for the
well-being of Nancy Pelosi as she was
concerned
she was concerned on January 6th she was
concerned about them she was concerned
about well she was concerned about
Republicans on January 6th
she was concerned about herself if
anything
and not even really herself she was
concerned about how this can be
politically exploited
I I don't think there's anyone in
America happier about January 6 than
Nancy Pelosi I mean really all the
Democrats
they're thrilled they could not be
happier about it they so it's it's the
best thing that ever happened to them
they're so happy that it happened
obviously
now has Nancy Pelosi uh what about
actual violence against Republicans and
Rand Paul was attacked when uh Bernie
bro shot up a GOP baseball game
conservatives and Republicans being
canvassers and campaigners being being
assaulted you know there's been several
different cases of that one one kid was
run over by a car
um what does Nancy Pelosi said about
that
where has her concern been
I guess she's thoughts and prayer she's
keeping it to herself but she's she's
really deeply concerned sure okay
um Joe Biden also is the other thing you
know when when Democrats are getting
desperate well we know about all the
threat to democracy stuff but the other
thing they do
right on cue as we get close to the
election is they start ranting and
raving about the national Republicans
that are coming to take away your Social
Security let's listen a little bit of
this
then Along Came Senator Johnson
from Wisconsin
he says five years too long to wait
no I it's hard to believe no I really
mean it it's hard to believe
he says it takes that that's too long
every year
every single year it should be on the
chopping block along with veterans
benefits and everything else the federal
budget
Congress doesn't vote affirmatively keep
it it goes away gone
you've been paying the Social Security
your whole life
you earned it
now these guys want to take it away who
in the hell do they think they are
excuse my language
[Applause]
yeah
yeah get him
just imagine you get those imaginary
child care workers okay
so you still get the idea you're paying
Social Security they want to take away
your Social Security no one
no Republican is talking about taking
away Social Security that this that does
not exist
okay
um that's why we always we always hear
them quoted it's the interesting things
that we we anytime you hear a republican
you hear about a republican wants to
take away Social Security it's always
coming from Democrats who are insisting
that their Republicans know yet but you
don't hear you don't see the Republicans
you know you're not going to find very
many clips of Republicans uh in front of
a microphone talking about why we need
to just get rid of Social Security
altogether
because that none of them are saying
that
that's just that's just that just
doesn't exist it's Republicans and
Democrats together
uh both understand that it would be
electoral suicide
to actually advocate for getting rid of
Social Security because for one thing
you would be directly ticking off
um the demographic graphic of people who
are most likely to vote which would be
older people so they're just not going
to do it
now I'm not a republican elected
official and I can say that in my there
are many things that I will say and do
say that uh you can't blame Republicans
for because they're not going to say
these things uh but I am willing to say
that I I do think we need to get away
from Social Security I think the whole
thing is a it's a Ponzi scheme I don't
think it is it is it's a Ponzi scheme
it's a scam
and uh of course we know that this whole
idea that you you're paying into Social
Security and then you're taking out what
you paid in no the money you paid into
it is gone it's been spent already it's
not like they keep it in some box
somewhere in a safe and it's got your
name on it and then when you turn you
know when you when you become when you
come of age they just open up the box
and they start Doling it back out to you
that's not how it works
they already spent the money it is a
scam
and I also know by that that you know 30
years hence when I'm eligible for Social
Security it's not going to be available
to me because it's just it can't go on
it's it is it's doomed for failure
eventually it's going to the whole
thing's going to implode
um so I am paying substantially into a
system that that I almost certainly will
not benefit from
so
if politicians are not in either party
had the courage for it then we would
really be having a conversation about
how do we get away now you can't pull it
away all at once I'm not saying that but
we've got to figure out a way this
system has failed it's it's ridiculous
to begin with the idea that we want the
government to take our money and store
it away for us for retirement no thank
you very much I'd like to do that myself
I'd like to have that money myself I'd
be better off just keeping it under a
mattress than letting you have it
yeah saving for retirement's a good idea
I don't I'm not going to trust that to
you I don't trust my I don't want to
trust my retirement plan to you
I'm not given a choice though
so it's a it's a it's a crazy system
it's a failed system uh and we should
get away from it but no one is talking
about getting away from it uh
except for me and a few other crazy
podcasters okay
um
speaking of ranting and raving on the
campaign Trail I want to play this for
you also is the actress Jennifer Lewis
who was
on the The Campaign Trail in uh I don't
know where this I think it's in Florida
and
anyway there's no way to really set this
up just listen to what she says
Marco Rubio is alive
he is y'all see that debate
lied his ass off
Val demmings
will win
she will win
she will win
[Applause]
so I say to Marco
and all those other weak men
before you lie to us
remember Rosa sat on that bus
[Applause]
what
before
you tell
your tail
remember Mandela sat in that jail
[Applause]
none of this what does this have to do
with anything none of this oh you do
anything
you remember Dr King
[Applause]
before you cheat and steal
I dare you to Google him until
there it is
okay
all right so we can turn it off fine
I was waiting for that you know you knew
Emmett Till was gonna get was good it
was gonna uh make its way into it just
just just to show you how cynical and
ridiculous these people are
uh Emmett Till
was killed
70 years ago almost 70 years ago
and yet the Democrats bring him up
every day I mean he comes up on on the
ca Emmett Till
comes up as a campaign issue
70 years later
that's how cynical and ridiculous these
people are
what does Emmett Till It's this which
occurred 70 years ago what does that
have to do with a with a with a race in
Florida
I mean it also shows you by the way that
um when they wanna you know they wanna
absurdly tie Republicans to hate crimes
or whatever and never mind the fact that
you know back then
of course the people who were actually
lynching black people were Democrats but
uh never mind that for a moment
so they want to find a way to link
Republicans to hate crimes uh they got
to go back to Emmett Till They gotta go
back 70 years
because we're also they're you know
they're they're not going to go back to
Jesse smallett
I mean they did you know even even they
won't bring him up anymore
that's how far back they have to go
um
and they're willing to do it now they'll
use him as a as an Applause line the
campaign Trail 70 years later all right
I also want to mention this this is from
uh variety before we get to the comment
section
it says at the height of the backlash
against JK Rowling over her views on the
transgender Community Harry Potter star
Daniel Radcliffe published an open
letter in which he proclaimed trans
women are women in a new interview with
Indie wire Radcliffe opened up about why
he decided to speak out publicly against
the author who essentially gave him his
acting career
he said the reason I felt very very much
as though I needed to say something when
I did was because particularly since
finishing Potter I've met so many queer
and trans kids and young people had a
huge amount of identification with
Potter on that and so seeing them hurt
on that day I was like I wanted them to
know that not everybody in the franchise
felt that way and that was really
important
okay now even for even aside from the
fact
that he's totally wrong on the
transgender issue of course he's
completely wrong about that and he's
defending the transing of kids and he's
wrong to do that
he also
just
even putting that aside
you you owe it to JK Rowling
to keep your stupid ungrateful mouth
shut actually you you actually owe that
to her
um
because she did in fact give you her
your career like you wouldn't exist in
the industry like nobody would know your
name without her
so she gave you everything that you have
and so you actually owe it to her you
owe some loyalty to her
so see all these Harry Potter actors and
there were a few that didn't speak out
against her against JK Rowling there
might have been one or two that actually
defended her
and I think one of them died recently
and and the left was dancing on his
grave obviously
um
but most of the Harry Potter actors came
out against her
which again they're wrong on the facts
they're wrong about the issue
but also where's the Loyalty how about
having some loyalty to a woman who gave
you your whole career your you know
everything that you have is because of
her about a little bit of loyalty for
that
now that doesn't mean that if someone is
your friend or if someone uh helped you
professionally that you can never under
any circumstances criticize them I mean
there might be something really horrific
they could do where you feel like you
need to speak out
but just jumping on a dog pile
on someone who again gave you everything
that you have
on top of you being wrong you're also a
disloyal rat
along with it
which is worth noting all right let's
get to the comment section
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Jessica says love the opening I'm still
waiting for apologies from family
members who accuse me of being a
murderer for choosing to be around my
parents who weren't even in the more
susceptible age range pretty sure I'll
be waiting forever yeah so many stories
like that in families I mean this is one
of the saddest things is how this
coveted stuff just tore families apart
uh because you had some members of the
family that decided to be
you know who became uh just radically
paranoid and or were willing to cut off
communication and and you know to to cut
off
seeing their own family for years if
necessary because they're so afraid now
unfortunately I didn't have to deal with
that in my in my family because we were
all
you know we were we were getting
together at the height of all of this
and uh of course we're not wearing masks
or anything like that but I always felt
bad for the families that had to deal
with that
um Kelly says my mother died alone in a
hospital after being denied any visits
at the assisted living facility where
she resided I spoke to her every day but
did not get to see her or hug her for
over a year I couldn't even honor her
last wish which was holding her hand
when she passed she never met her first
great grandchild I know what she died of
it wasn't coveted I know that it was it
says as her cause of death that it was
covered but I also know she died of
loneliness they want amnesty oh hell no
that's a horrific story and uh there are
so many like it
and this is one of the reasons why there
can't be amnesty or forgiveness because
you took something away
that cannot be
given back I mean you have caused harm
that that that cannot be
remedied
uh
Jess says Matt's ability to pick apart
the most random irrelevant things such
as an almost 100 year old Disney story
is what makes him totally relatable to
us and infuriating to the left it really
is a level of Genius not many have
reached well okay I'll accept that
although I won't accept I mean the
genius part I will take that humbly but
uh I will not accept that for example
the fact that Snow White directly
promotes felony breaking and entering
and kidnapping is irrelevant I don't I
don't see that as an irrelevant fact at
all
my Lamborghini says you have to accept
you are wrong admit you are wrong feel
actual remorse then apologize and then
forgiveness can start
yeah that's true you know actual
reconciliation
okay so there's forgiveness
which is which is offered
by the the the aggrieved party but for
there to be actual reconciliation in
order to move on as that article said
yesterday
um that's a two-way street
and the other party concerned here is
not participating
Mark says Matt I'm curious about your
opinion of the manosphere and the
commentators thinkers who speak
specifically to men and about
masculinity I've heard you mentioned
some figures from that world in passing
but do you have an opinion on them in
general
uh well I think it's great that there
are people out there thinking about
issues that affect men and talking to
men and speaking up for men and about
men
that's all great you know I'm pretty
sure that manosphere is a term used by
the left at least I think it is
kind of I don't know pejorative to
describe anyone in that world I don't
know if the people in that space
identify with it themselves or not but
either way
um uh yeah I suppose my general opinion
is that it's it's good that it exists
what I will say again speaking generally
is because I know that there you know
there are some men out there figures who
this is what they do they talk about
they talk especially about issues that
affect men and again I think it's good
but when it comes to men who speak about
masculinity or purport to defend it or
model it I am personally not going to
look to you for insight on the subject
if you aren't married with kids
I mean with a few exceptions I'm I'm
just not looking there because as a
married man with six kids now I just
haven't found that a a single dude has
much to say about masculinity that's
going to be enlightening or useful to me
in my station in life
because one of the most fundamental
expressions of masculinity is uh you
know it's it's fulfillment is to get
married and have kids
um it's something that nearly every man
is called to not all
but nearly every and even the men who
are not called to to uh marriage and
family life are still called to fulfill
a father-like role you know a role of
paternal service in society and there
are other ways to do that like in
religious life for example I mean we in
Catholic church we call priests fathers
and we we use that term for a reason
so
um I personally need to see that you're
doing that before I'm going to per
before I'm going to look to you for
wisdom
and uh if I have one criticism maybe of
of
some of the guys who have taken this on
as their vocation is and this again it's
this is not true of all of them
but um if you're going to talk about
masculinity then I think this has to be
a central part of your message is
encouraging marriage family and
fatherhood
and there are plenty of men who talk
about these issues and do encourage that
Jordan Peterson being one of them
um
but then there are others who don't it
was like that's that's they they have
some interesting things to say about
masculinity but that doesn't either they
just don't factor that in at all or or
sometimes they might actively discourage
it
which means that you are while trying to
defend masculinity you are discouraging
its most important
um
expression
which doesn't make any sense to me
recessions aren't recessions inflation
is good men are women if you're more
confused than usual lately it's by
Design the left thinks they have a
monopoly on the definition of words and
can silence you but they can't and if
you simply push back the House of Cards
collapse just look at my film what is a
woman it caused a rift in the space-time
Continuum just because I asked a
question you know the month that came
out the daily wire had more members sign
up than at any other time in his history
more than 5 000 audience ratings on
Rotten Tomatoes later and the film still
has people talking which is great
because the more we bring these
conversations out into the open and the
more we confront the madness the sooner
we'll hopefully end if you haven't seen
it yet go to dailywire.com Walsh to
become a member and watch the film today
now let's get to our daily cancellation
foreign
I'm very excited about this daily
cancellation I finally get a chance to
cancel Ann Hathaway I've held a grudge
against this woman ever since my wife
early in our marriage forced me to go to
the theater with her and uh and with her
mom and her sister to watch Les
Miserables it was the worst experience
of my life every actor in the film was
deeply and painfully annoying none of
them would stop singing at all they sang
the entire time from start to finish yet
even a mid-stall of that Anne Hathaway
managed to be irritating and
insufferable on a level that even
Russell Crowe's blubbering off key
performance couldn't reach a couple of
years later I went with much higher
hopes to go see Interstellar and there
was Anne Hathaway again helping to ruin
the film with her cringy saccharin
speeches about the Transcendent Power of
Love
I wanted to see a movie about deep space
exploration I was hoping there'd be
aliens instead I got no aliens only a
little bit of space exploration in
exchange for a lot of scenes of Anne
Hathaway and Jessica Chastain sulking
and whining and giving corny sermons so
the only thing that would made it worse
is if they started singing which
thankfully they didn't all that to say
this cancellation is a long time coming
Hathaway's appearance this week on The
View has uh I think finally provided me
the opportunity that I've been waiting
for
let's watch
you know the devilish product didn't
turn 16 this summer yes the time flies
boy so you wrote this on Instagram quote
I am struck by the fact that the young
female characters in this movie built
their lives and careers in a country
then honored their right to have Choice
over their own reproductive Health see
you in the fight so why did you write
that why was it important to you to you
to write something like that because
we're in the fight yeah we're in the
fight every day we're in the fight every
minute and you mentioned the devil's
product turning sweet 16 yeah some 16
year old's life has been irrevocably
changed yeah because of the current
overturning of Roe v Wade and in this
character I played a young woman who was
starting out her career
and when you are a young woman starting
out your career your reproductive
Destiny matters a great deal of course
and I just
it had just happened and I just
I think about it all the time I think we
all think about it all the time and um
and what's implications are and what it
means to live in a country that
puts us in this position again
yeah yeah again and so if I were to play
that role nowadays I couldn't take that
for granted I couldn't take that freedom
for granted the freedom of choice and by
the way I'm not this is not a moral
conversation about abortion right this
is a practical conversation about
women's rights and by the way human
rights because women's rights are human
rights and the freedom that we all need
to be able to to choose and build our
lives and have access to excellent
Health Care see this is exactly what you
did in interstellar just babbling and
coherently of course if you listen to
any leftists when they talk about
abortion or really any other subject at
all all that any of them do is Babble
incoherently so
let's try to sift through this she says
that uh it Grieves her to consider that
the young female characters in Devil
Wears Prada would not be able to have
abortions if the film was set in the
current day it is to begin with
extremely strange to worry about the
availability of abortion for fictional
characters
um now I I've never seen The Devil Wears
Prada but I'm pretty sure that the film
is largely set in New York
women in New York can still get
abortions unless they don't exist
because they're fictional which is a
logistical problem that will prevent
them from doing a lot of things
including getting abortions also again
not having seen it my impression is that
the movie has a rather dim view of
selfish career-obsessed people
um that's like the Devil Wears Prada
that's so part of the moral of the story
from what I understand is that there's
more to life than professional ambition
yet Hathaway's takeaway is that women
need to be able to kill their children
so they can focus more on career
advancement
there seems to be a little bit of a
disconnect here she also speaks about
reproductive Destiny which of course is
exactly the sort of asinine hackneyed
phrase you would expect Anne Hathaway to
use when discussing abortion
um it's it's it's not the sort of
wording that I would ever choose
but since she brought it up
let us ask this question
reproductive Destiny Okay well once a
woman has conceived a child
what is her reproductive Destiny the
word destiny implies a force outside of
the individual a message a mission from
Beyond ourselves so what is this Force
call it nature call it the universe call
it as I do God what is this Force trying
to say to the woman what is her Destiny
now that she has conceived the child in
her womb is it her Destiny to partake in
the joy and beauty and fulfillment of
motherhood
or is it her Destiny to Peg some
abortionist to kill her baby and throw
his body into a medical waste dumpster
I would say the former
indeed how could it be anyone's
reproductive Destiny to reject their
reproductive capacity and violently
destroy the human life that they have
reproduced
to call such a choice reproductive
Destiny seems uh bizarre to say the
least
Hathaway also claims that she's not
interested in having a moral
conversation about abortion but rather a
practical conversation about women's
rights
well except that a conversation about
rights is automatically a conversation
about morality you cannot extract the
concept of morality from the concept of
Human Rights
a practical conversation a real
practical conversation is one that is
not concerned with theories or ideas at
all
but but human rights are a theory they
are an idea
they're a moral idea that isn't to say
they don't exist
but rather that they exist in the moral
realm they don't exist physically
practically like a chair or a rock or
the ocean exists so to say that you
don't want to talk about morality you
just want to talk about human rights
that is to speak gibberish human rights
are a moral concept the minute you bring
them up you have entered into the moral
Realm
but that's not where Anne Hathaway wants
to be because she knows that she can't
actually defend abortion on moral
grounds none of these people can
and that's the issue
but she had more to say and it only gets
dumber from here so let's continue
another thing and just without going to
too many details my own personal
experience with abortion and I don't
think we talk about this enough abortion
can be another word for Mercy we don't
know we don't know it's not a world in
which we know that no two pregnancies
are alike and it follows that no two
lives are like that follows that no two
conceptions are alike so how can we have
a law how can we have a point of view on
this that says we must treat everything
the same and where I come at it from is
when you allow for choice you allow for
flexibility which is what we need in
order to be human so that anyway I just
wanted to include that question
especially for that it's not it's not
set in stone just because you get
pregnant doesn't mean you get to keep
that baby yeah it's a health decision
and it can be it really can be yeah
abortion is another word for Mercy she
says but Mercy for whom
Mercy for the child who's being killed
that's not Mercy the child has an entire
life ahead of him or he should
you're taking that away You're deciding
for him that his life is not worth
living you're erasing all of his
potential all that could have been
and you're not giving him a choice in
the matter
there's no mercy in that it's the
opposite of Mercy because it's the
opposite of empathy and you can't have
mercy without empathy
or do you mean that it's merciful to the
woman are you saying that killing a
child is an act of Mercy to the child's
mother
well no mercy to the mother is to help
her to give her the resources she needs
Mercy is what pregnancy centers provide
Mercy is their Ministry it's what they
do
abortion clinics on the other hand are
vultures
they prey on fear and misery they cash
in on it they feed off of it they profit
off of it
they sell guilt they sell regret they
sell loneliness
while taking away the love and joy of
motherhood that's not Mercy it's
mercenary
so whichever way Hathaway meant it she's
wrong
though I'm not sure she knows how she
meant it because she's just babbling
which is what most defenses of abortion
boil down to incoherent Babel
and that is why Ann Hathaway is today
finally after all these years canceled
that'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]